-Amazing stuff happening.
But tonight, and I'm so happy
you chose our show,
you have a big announcement.
-I do.
I mean a lot of things --
[ Drumroll ]
Don't start so soon!
Oh, my God!
You're giving me
a heart attack already.
Gee, Quest over there,
he's like, "Let's go.
Let's keep it rolling."
Well, yeah,
I do have a big announcement.
I mean, I've done a lot
of exciting things this year.
You know, I've started
my own production company,
called
Unicorn Island Productions.
-Yeah.
Unicorn Island.
-And so, I'm really into just
creating dope things.
And so, I did I want to announce
something on this show,
but before I do, I want to say
I could not be more thrilled
to do it on this show,
and I really do mean this,
Jimmy, because I know you all
watch him,
and he's so funny,
but Jimmy is one of the nicest
human beings on this planet.
Truly, I mean that.
I really, really mean that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
From the very first time
I came on this show --
From the very first time I came
till right now,
you've been such a supporter
and such a champion.
So I want to
say thank you to you
for letting me announce it
on this show,
and I'm forever grateful.
But I do have an announcement,
and that is
that your girl is getting her
own NBC late-night show!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
♪♪
Welcome!
-Thank you!
-Congratulations!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, wait.
Let's stop.
You're getting your own show?
-I am.
And to clarify,
it's not Jimmy's slot.
-Okay, I was gonna say,
that would be
a horrible announcement.
"Yeah. Oh. Yeah."
-And this is how you find out.
-The new host of
"The Tonight Show," yeah.
I know, and I'm so excited.
But it's called --
Can I tell you what it's called?
-Yes. It has a name?
-It has a name.
-Yes.
-It's called "A Little Late
with Lilly Singh."
-Oh, come on.
-I know, I know.
-When does it premiere?
Do we know?
-So, fallish,
probably September.
-Wow.
-And I'm so excited because
I truly get to create a show
from scratch.
You know,
I get to make it inclusive,
I get to create comedy segments
and interview people
and really create something
that I believe in.
And I'm so honored and humbled.
-What's the show gonna be like?
-Kind of like
my YouTube channel, but just,
you know, now I have more
than three staff members.
[ Laughter ]
And my sound guy
won't also be an extra
and won't also
write the scripts.
So, it's like -- it's nice.
-So it's gonna be me,
then Seth Meyers, and then you.
-Yeah!
-You're in the
NBC late-night family.
-I mean...
-That's good stuff.
-Can I just say...?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a good block.
That's a good block right there.
-Can I just say --
I mean, I got to just say
a huge shout-out to all the
women who have been before me
and are currently in the space,
because I couldn't have done it
without them paving the path.
Truly, I couldn't have.
-I totally agree.
-But I do think
it's a little awesome
for Indian-Canadian women, also.
-Aha! Come on, man.
Breaking records.
-So I'm super-honored
and humbled.
-Are you gonna have a desk?
-I don't know.
I'm trying to decide
if I want a desk.
I really don't know.
-Do you want to try it out?
-Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay.
All right.
Thank you so much.
-I love your energy.
I love your energy.
-Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, my friend.
Congrats on your success.
-Hello, my friend.
"Congrats on your success."
[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God.
This is pretty --
Should I ask you
some questions, then?
-Yeah, go ahead.
-All right, cool.
So, Jimmy --
Jimmy Fallon, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love this guy.
Also has one of the biggest
YouTube channels in the world.
So, do you have any advice
for a new host?
Asking for a friend.
[ Laughter ]
Do you have any advice
for someone that might,
you know, be hosting?
-My advice -- don't get sick.
-Cool.
-You can't get sick.
There's so many people
that depend on you, crew-wise.
They have to feed
their families, but also,
the millions of people watching.
They need to see,
so do not get sick.
If you can control that
in anyway.
-Is it too late for me
to go back?
[ Laughter ]
-I think my real advice is,
and you already know this --
that's why
you're very successful --
is just to be yourself.
And you're fantastic as you.
Everyone can smell
if you're phony or not yourself,
and don't be somebody else,
be you,
and that's why you're great.
-Thank you so much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And what do you do
when you're nervous?
What do you do
-How do you get rid of nerves?
-The adrenaline just takes over.
It's just such a rush.
It's so much fun.
And you're gonna have
so many shows where you're just
gonna mess up,
and you're gonna be like,
"Oh, my God, it's the worst,"
and no one will remember it.
-I love that.
-You'll be the only person
that remembers.
-Well, I just hope I am
half of the host that you are.
-Oh. You are going to be
better than me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Actually, we have someone here
that would like to wish you
congratulations.
-What to the who now?
-Yeah.
Because you're in
the NBC late-night family,
everyone, please welcome
the host of
"Late Night with Seth Meyers,"
Seth Meyers!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome to the family!
[ Cheers and applause ]
So happy are we!
-Thank you.
Oh, my God.
-Very nice of you, Seth.
Thank you for doing this.
Lilly, we're so happy for you.
I want to take a photo now
that we're in the NBC family.
Let's do a cheesy family photo.
-Let's do it.
-Here we go.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Cheers, congratulations,
good luck.
To many, many years.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're a host now.
You want to toss to break?
-All right, yeah, yeah, okay.
Listen, we'll be right back
with stand-up comedy
from Jimmy Carr,
so stick around.
-Oh, that was very good.
That was very good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪